when people ask what I do it's really
kind of a fun interaction for me I said
oh I'm a neon tube bender
and while the words that I'm saying they
understand what those are and they know
the word neon it doesn't register
putting them together in terms of a job
in their mind so they kind of gloss over
and go blank I have to make the pattern
for the neon which is a full-sized
rendering in Reverse because we Bend all
of neon face down on the table so that
the front is flat I don't even look at
it like letters it's all broken down in
my mind is like what Bend is this and
how do I mark it and then I put that
section of glass in the fire and then I
bring it back to the table when it's hot
and lay it down on the pattern to make
sure it sets just right and then I go
back in right away to do the next Bend
that's right next to it right as you
bend the glass the outer wall wants to
collapse because it's molten you give a
quick puff of air through your blow hose
at that moment and it brings the
diameter of the glass back to what it
was when you're bending the glass it's
kind of really like by feel or when it's
ready there's no there's not a lot of
visual cues the tactile nature of neon
is pretty important not only are you
handling the smooth hard glass it turns
into a wet noodle when you heat it but
you have wood blocks that you use to
cool off the glass so we can continue
working pretty rapidly we use soft
graphite pencils to mark the glass we
use really hard metal files to cut it
you're charring the table and the paper
every tool that we use
is a different touch and then also the
smells I have the memories of the
smelling of a burning pencil from 30
years ago when I was learning I smelled
that smell and it's like oh yeah I
remember that when I was in college I
needed a part-time job and there was a
retail neon store that had like palm
trees and flamingos and things like that
so basically I babysat the store and
after two years of doing that my boss
said hey why don't you learn the
processing part and then she said why
don't you go ahead and do an
apprenticeship with the tube bender I
was in school full-time
I was working 30 plus hours a week and
our glassblower - bender only worked in
the evenings so I was not really that
excited about doing an apprenticeship it
was always like my back pocket trade
that I mostly stuck with I didn't really
go on to pursue my studies in cognitive
science there's a very strong element of
science behind the process neon gases
are inert they need a pure clean
environment inside the tube once the
tube is bent we heat up the tube to 250
degrees Celsius with electricity we burn
off all impurities which includes any
like air molecules or dirt so if those
materials that are being used to produce
that part are inferior or contaminated
with some kind of chemical it's going to
stay in that tube it's going to corrode
and degrade really the neon gas
molecules
I've well-built neon tube aside from its
power supply but a well-built neon tube
could last 10 20 30 years in this shop
I've been here 10 years
I prefer Oakland just because it's an
artist community it used to be way more
industrial way more other other people
building things and now slowly these
warehouse spaces are being converted to
office space
I don't just do stuff for large
companies I do work with several artists
in the Bay Area that just want to add
neon to something or want somethin in
neon made and that that's pretty
interesting because they're always
challenging you have to kind of figure
out how to make it work you know here's
my concept here's what I envisioned it
to be and then I have to sit down with
it and and mentally plot and plan how
it's going to come together